you take your causes seriously but you  don't take yourself too seriously you  love skittles you got fine because you  wore skittles shoes once and the NFL  find you and when I met with you you  actually had skittles on you the first  time when I met you when we shot that  piece from for Mortal Kombat yeah and  you were talking about skittles and I  thought this guy really loves skittles  you are famous for jumping backwards  into the end zone and I thought maybe  it's a long dream of yours to jump  backwards into an end zone filled with  skittles is that in fact your dream  Marshawn Lynch it'll only help us out of  loser yes do you what you gonna play  this sound like I said you like to jump  backwards  [Applause]  he's just I just I just got you the ball  that's the end zone right there the  game's on the line  [Music]  [Applause]  yeah  [Applause]